[Music]
we're on the world scientists are
becoming increasingly alarmed about a
threat to our environment that we're
just starting to understand
microplastics and other man-made
materials seeping into our oceans and
seas
roxanna saberi joined researchers with
the environmental group greenpeace as
they traveled from antarctica to england
discovering just how much is polluting
the remote waters and what we can do to
slow the tide
in one of the most pristine places on
the planet
biologist kirsten thompson has been
searching for tiny
intruders so small they're invisible to
the naked eye
we'll have a look to see if there are
any microfibers in this water here
microfibers are microscopic strands shed
from synthetic fabrics that we wear
and wash there are also fragments of
plastic
products like bottles and bags
scientists estimate around 3 million
tons of microfibers now pollute our
oceans
even reaching antarctica where we
traveled a year ago
and sadly what we do around the coast
in all the areas in europe and the
states
actually has an impact from such
pristine environment here
thousands of miles away do you know what
the effects are
we know that they're found in the guts
of fish and we know that
in some cases that microfibers and
microplastics can accumulate
up the food chain all the way to us
human beings
possibly thompson sent sea water samples
from four sites in the antarctic
to this greenpeace lab in exeter england
where scientists david santillo and his
team
poured over them for months what they've
now discovered
is disheartening on this one i mean you
can see the fiber there
microfibers in every sample similar to
what they'd found at the same sites
two years earlier it is a piece of
microplastic it's a piece of polyester
floating out there in antarctic waters
people could say these particles are so
tiny
how could they possibly be dangerous we
don't know what the biological
consequences of that are at the moment
what we do know is that these
microplastics are there
that exposure is occurring and really it
shouldn't be occurring this is part of a
man-made problem
that has now gone global and that
problem
threatens to become part of the fabric
of our oceans
plastic is so so durable that these even
these little pieces
will remain in the environment for for
years and years like hundreds of years
hundreds of years but environmentalists
say there are solutions
like using special filters or bags and
washing machines
to catch some microfibers from escaping
through wastewater
into rivers and seas but they say what
we really need to do
is make and use less plastic
we can focus on buying clothes that
don't contain plastics and that are more
made of natural fibers so that when
if fibres do escape our washing machines
they break down in the environment we
should be using
much more sustainable materials every
day we just need to think about it
our planet she says needs healthy oceans
and we have the power to protect them
for cbs this morning saturday roxanna
suberi
exeter england see that little guy just
chilling there
you end on a good note yeah i said it
right exactly think of that little guy
well that's
trying to save him yeah but three
million tons of microfibers
in our ocean and growing that's crazy